und wie geschlossen in der tat die eu da
steht und auch die menschen das konnte
man gestern abend auch eine frankfurter
beobachten beispielsweise da sind
tausende auf die straße gegangen das war
ein public viewing der anderen art hat
man nicht fußball geschaut sondern den
ukrainischen präsidenten des elends geht
er erst zu einer schweigeminute auf rief
und dann bekam er großen applaus
aber sie lenski hat sich in einer
anderen rede in der nacht auch an die
nato gewarnt und hat diese scharf
kritisiert mit folgenden worten ich hole
die gerichtskasse also indem sie die
schaffung einer flugverbotszone
verweigert hat die führung der
militärallianz grünes licht für weitere
bombardierungen ukrainischer städte und
dörfer gegeben kritik
musste ludwig all die menschen die von
heute an sterben werden auch ihretwegen
sterben wegen ihrer schwäche wegen ihrer
abkopplung ihres favorisierten
also eine geradezu wütender ukrainischer
präsident see landscape studio ist bild
lei chef claus strunz klaus wir haben
den heldenmut des elends kies immer
beobachtet stehen fest an seiner seite
jetzt diese harsche kritik an der nato
er wirft uns und wir sind ja teil der
nato vor dass wir mit verantwortlich
sind für weitere tote ist dass der eine
kleine schritte jetzt vielleicht zu weit
geht uns diesen vorwurf zu machen also
natürlich kann man alles verstehen was
er sagt eine stadt die eingekesselt ist
ein land des überfalles brüder
schwestern väter mütter kinder die
sterben im bombenhagel der russen da
kann ich jedes wort unterschreiben aber
er lastet auch eine menge verantwortung
auf sich sein chef seine schärfste seine
schärfste waffe jetzt ist sozusagen die
moralkeule gegen den westen was meine
ich damit eigentlich heißt seine rede
die wir gerade gehört haben mehr
übersetzt wenn wir nicht bereit sind
unsere brüder und schwestern sterben
zu lassen
dann verhalten wir uns unverantwortlich
der ukraine gegenüber warum weil er sagt
ja nato müsste sich mehr engagieren und
müsste
flugverbotszonen machen das würde aber
ein eingriff und ein über als übergriff
gewertet werden und damit die nächste
eskalationsstufe richtung nicht
weltkrieg aber zumindest einer großen
eskalation als und ich glaube dass er
jetzt in einem bereich wo achtgeben muss
steht mir nicht zu ihnen zu belehren es
ist aber ein gefühl aus mitgefühl zu 8
geben muss dass die stimmung im westen
nicht kippt weil ich glaube dass ganz
viele menschen sagen ja wir müssen alles
tun für die ukraine ja wir müssen auch
noch mehr waffen liefern ja wir müssen
uns um die flüchtlinge kümmern wir
müssen sie in großer humanität aufnehmen
aber ich glaube im westen sind doch die
allermeisten menschen nicht bereit dass
ihre kinder und sich selbst in einen
krieg hineingezogen werden der russland
den russland über die ukraine gebracht
hat da glaube ich ist dann eine sperre
und eine erinnerung ist mir noch wichtig
unser bündnis wenn ich das mal so sagen
darf ist ja die nato und unsere
anforderungen an die nato muss sein die
ukraine nach möglichkeit zu unterstützen
aber vor allem uns zu schützen und im
moment erscheint es mir als
verantwortungsvolle politik der nato
eben nicht den forderungen von selensky
bis ins detail nachzukommen sondern klar
zu machen dass wir hier nicht eingreifen
jedenfalls nicht militärisch eingreifen
und auch nicht so dass wladimir putin es
als militärischen eingriff werden könnte
das ist ja sozusagen zwischen der
rechtlichen situation und der
tatsächlichen situation unterschiedlich
gleichzeitig stecken wir in einem
furchtbaren dilemma jede stunde die
vergeht kann todesopfer zur folge haben
und wir finden im moment eigentlich kein
weg aus dieser situation heraus welches
szenario
könnte man mal ins auge fassen was
könnte ein realistisches
wahrscheinliches szenario seien um
irgendwie aus dieser situation
herauszukommen also erstmal muss ich
noch sagen wenn sie lenski formuliert
sozusagen auch ich bin schuld dass jetzt
menschen in der ukraine starben das ist
ja stark zugespitzt aber der kern seiner
aussage weil ihr im vest er meint die
nato aber damit natürlich uns alle nicht
wirklich ein greift deshalb müssen von
jetzt dann sehr viele menschen sterben
den schuh sage ich mal ziehe ich mir
nicht an weil ich glaube schon dass im
westen viel getan worden ist in der nato
in der eu und wenn du die szenarien
anspricht sehe ich im prinzip nur zwei
die sogar miteinander zusammenhängen
können das eine ist die ukraine muss auf
zeit spielen also jeder tag der ins land
geht und nicht die übernahme von kiew
durch die russen zur folge hat sondern
hier verteidigt es ist ein guter tag
weil es ein weiterer tag ist der die
diplomatie wieder anspringen lassen kann
und meine persönliche weise auf das
ganze ist das selensky und seine
regierung auch dem gedanken
perspektivisch wird näher treten müssen
die ukraine in eine neutralität zu
führen sowie österreich neutrales sowie
die schweiz neutrales eine wehrhafte
neutralität der vorteil daran wäre dem
könnte der westen zustimmen dem könnte
sogar wladimir putin zu stimmen denn das
war eines seiner erklärten kriegsziele
die ukraine zu entmilitarisierten und
sozusagen als puffer zum westen zu haben
ein wort noch aus westlicher sicht ich
hätte auch nichts gegen so einen
neutralen puffer zwischen russland und
den grenzen der natur ganz kurz noch
eine frage weil hier gerade die aktuelle
meldung herein kommt die eu setzt jetzt
auf die vermittlung chinas das sagt der
eu
außenbeauftragte borel wie realistisch
ist es gut das ist der nächste
naheliegende zug in dem großen
schachspiel sozusagen in dem großes katz
der welt der atego spiel bislang sendet
china allerdings keine wirklichen
hinweise darauf dass sie sich von der
seite wladimir putins entfernen können
das ist ja eher im gegenteil so dass
putin bei china nachgefragt hat was die
reaktion sein wird wenn er den überfall
auf die ukraine macht und das einzig
wirkliche interesse von china war warten
sie bitte damit herr diktator bis die
olympischen spiele vorbei sind damit uns
nicht die bilder versaut werden wenn das
die haltung von china in diesem konflikt
ist dann wird dieser vermittlungsversuch
scheitern
klaus kunz vielen dank